since darth maul's first appearance he's
quickly rocketed into fan favorite
status
but there's a lot of misinformation out
there about the sith apprentice
fortunately we can debunk these myths
and set the record straight about one of
the galaxy's greatest baddies
the phantom menace opens during a time
of relative peace and prosperity for the
galaxy
but as with any good story there's
trouble on the horizon
the jedi order has begun to feel
disturbances in the force and rumblings
of an approaching conflict
qui-gon jinn a jedi master and his
padawan obi-wan kenobi
are some of the first to sense this
disturbance as the two jedi race to
complete their mission to avoid an
all-out war
their path becomes dogged by a phantom
of the dark side of the force
that phantom none other than darth maul
darth maul is responsible for setting
into motion the events that sparked the
downfall of the jedi order and the rise
of the empire
his integral role in the lore of star
wars is why it's so important to get his
backstory and the facts about him right
these small details cause large ripples
across the greater universe of star wars
they affect everything from the dark
criminal underbelly of the galaxy to the
highest
echelons of the ruling class for many
fans of star wars the word sith in
episode 1 the phantom menace was a
revelation
it was the first time many had heard the
term used to describe what until then
most simply called the dark side of the
force
it made sense that there would be an
evil and ominous order guarding the dark
side as counterparts to the jedi
and now we finally knew their name but
the history of the term sith
actually stretches back to the earliest
days of star wars lore
before star wars rocked the world of pop
culture and changed the face of cinema
forever
it was all just whirling thoughts inside
of the head of young filmmaker george
lucas
we think of characters like luke
skywalker as being almost living people
themselves because they seem
so real and unchangeable but these
characters and the story surrounding
them have undergone
many drafts and revisions the term sith
was actually first
used in an early draft of a new hope
this was back when the entire saga
still lived in george lucas's head as
the star wars
while most of the changes and omissions
in the final theatrical release of a new
hope were for the better
it's pretty cool that the sith made
their appearance decades later with
darth maul hunting down
our heroes an intimidating warrior like
darth maul
seems like an obvious candidate to be
the apprentice for the sith lord darth
sidious
but he wasn't necessarily the first
choice
here's where darth maul's family comes
into play like most powerful men darth
maul had an even more powerful mother
who raised him
mother talzin was the leader of the
night sisters a group of force sensitive
dathomirian women
who used the power of the force for
their own purposes
but since the force imbues its users
with otherworldly abilities
the night sisters were branded as
witches on their home planet
darth sidious knew of this powerful clan
of force users
and came to dathomir seeking an
apprentice he intended to pass on the
ways of the sith to a student who would
help him further his goals of destroying
the galactic republic
and the jedi order originally sidious
told mother talzin that he wanted her to
be his apprentice
a powerful force user in her own right
she seemed like a natural choice
but sidious betrayed her in a twisted
mockery of the jedi practice of teaching
younglings
sidious abducted her son the young darth
maul and raised him in the ways of the
sith
as with so much of the massive sprawling
lore of star wars there was still more
to uncover
in the star wars universe the term sith
originates from an ancient race of force
sensitive humanoids
hailing originally from the planet
moriband these people were known as the
sith and the entire race had a penchant
for the dark side
this force-wielding species eventually
dispersed and spread throughout the
galaxy
in the name of their once mighty
civilization came to refer to the order
of force users who allied with the dark
side
the sith had dark red skin and bodies
with bone spurs not too dissimilar to
darth maul
but while maul was one of the first
beings to be associated with the word
sith
he isn't actually a member of the sith
species
he hails from the planet dathomir
another world known for its force using
inhabitants darth maul is actually a
member of the species known as
zabrak the signature facial markings of
darth maul set him apart from other
villains in the star wars movies
they fascinated fans and cosplayers
across the world and
inspired a great deal of speculation and
imitation
since maul was the first member of his
species introduced to audiences
and given the fact that the facial
markings look like they could be natural
many fans thought that the black stripes
were simply a part of his species
natural markings
like the ring of horns on his head or
his haunting eyes we all assumed that
this was a hallmark of whatever species
maul hailed from
but when more about his origin story was
revealed fans learned that
others of his species had similar
markings it turns out that the marks are
actually
tattoos given to young male zabrak
warriors
darth maul got his tattoos before his
first birthday by his mother talzin the
leader of the night sisters
there's nothing more symbolic of a
warrior aligned with the force
be it dark side or light side than a
lightsaber these weapons of pure force
energy have become wildly popular with
fans worldwide
and the lore surrounding them is complex
and fascinating part of the training of
a jedi apprentice is the construction of
their own lightsaber
while they build their weapons padawan
discovered that the true power of these
swords comes from something known
as a kyber crystal they're used to focus
force energy giving the lightsaber its
blade
the reason they're so precious to the
jedi and the sith is that these crystals
are naturally attuned to the force when
a young jedi finds the right
kyber crystal to craft their lightsaber
they meditate with the crystal
aligning themselves to it until it takes
on a unique
color but when a sith builds a
lightsaber it's a much more violent
affair
they steal the kyber crystal from a
defeated jedi and meditate with it
seeking to break its connection with the
light side and turn it to the dark side
of the force
this process is known as bleeding the
crystal and it gives the sith weapons
their distinctive red hue
so if you were wondering how darth
maul's lightsaber got its particular
color
now you know this is a big one if you've
seen the phantom menace and saw obi-wan
cutting darth maul down then you
probably assumed that the sith
apprentice was no more
at the battle of naboo qui-gon jinn and
obi-wan kenobi finally confront darth
maul
qui-gon falls to the sith's superior
lightsaber techniques as obi-wan watches
helplessly
then kenobi with the fury of the force
on his side
assaults the sith in an epic lightsaber
battle which ends in darth maul getting
neatly sliced in half
the gruesome image of maul's severed
body falling into a dark abyss stuck
with fans for years
and everybody believed they'd seen the
last of the sith apprentice
but as in so many movies and tv shows
falling into a misty
seemingly bottomless pit doesn't mean
much even if you've been chopped in two
years later it was revealed that darth
maul didn't die from his injuries that
day
he used his powerful ties to the force
as well as his sheer will
and an all-consuming hatred nourished by
his sith training to cling to life
my hatred get my spirit intact even
though my body was not
yet i was lost and became a rabid animal
maul escaped through a garbage chute and
along with trash was brought to a
landfill planet where he crudely
constructed a set of robotic spider-like
legs
losing his mind in the process it must
have been pretty reassuring for luke
skywalker the first time he heard his
departed mentor obi-wan kenobi's voice
after losing his aunt and uncle the only
home he'd ever known
and the man who introduced him to the
space magic the jedi called the force
it was probably a big relief to know
that there was a way for the dead to
communicate with the living
oddly being able to defy death is
supposed to be the hallmark of the sith
it's what initially attracted anakin
skywalker to the dark side after all
however only those who've devoted their
lives to the light side of the force can
return as force ghosts
and impart advice to those still
inhabiting the mortal realm
in other words darth maul can never come
back as a force ghost
sure by the end of his long and exciting
life he wasn't a fan of the sith
but he never embraced the light side of
the force
anakin skywalker also known as darth
vader was able to return as a force
ghost because
in the end he renounced evil and turned
to the light
darth maul he was bad to the bone until
the day he died
taken from his homeworld and everything
he knew at a young age darth maul was
trained by one of the most powerful sith
lords the galaxy has ever known
darth sidious molded maul to be a living
weapon and tool of the dark side
the intense training and brainwashing he
was subjected to was nearly impossible
to break away from
and at first it seemed that darth maul
would be loyal to the sith
until the day he died this wasn't the
case
remember when we told you that he
survived being cut in half on naboo
well eventually he was rescued by his
brother as he recovered he was given a
more traditional set of robotic legs to
replace the spider-like ones he had
constructed
once he had finally healed maul set his
mind to a singular objective
revenge against kenobi unfortunately by
the time he was ready for battle once
again
darth sidious had already taken on darth
vader as his new apprentice
for the sith there can be only two a
master
and an apprentice and since vader was in
maul
was out instead he used his force powers
and his prowess in battle to set himself
up as a crime lord
becoming the shadow power behind the
ruler of the planet mandalore
while lurking in exile building a
criminal empire maul never lost sight of
his one true burning motivation
revenge against the man who'd bested him
obi-wan kenobi
had taken almost everything from maul
after cutting him down on nobu
after briefly battling once again for a
long time it seemed like that encounter
would be the last time
the two would ever meet but years later
darth maul would have his final showdown
the two wove in and out of each other's
lives during the clone wars and beyond
but it would be on tatooine the location
of their first encounter
where maul would meet his doom at the
hands of kenobi
years after the fall of the galactic
republic maul traced kenobi to his
desert hideout
it was here that the jedi kept a
watchful eye on a growing luke skywalker
the two old foes crossed sabers once
again and the outcome
was the same kenobi stood triumphant
this time we're good check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about star
wars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you